les semis chemillé et voitures blindés
allemands de la seconde guerre mondiale
la nouvelle stratégie militaire mise au
point par l'armée allemande est
appliquée en pologne le 1er septembre
1939 à la surprise générale paralyse à
l'ennemi à tel point qu'il fut privé de
la capacité et même de la volonté de
combattre napoléon n'aurait pas vu un
seul à autre chose que ce qu'il avait
toujours rêvé de faire lors de sa propre
campagne
après tout la campagne 2008 105 qui fit
plier les armes et l'autriche et de
russie à austerlitz ne découle est elle
pas de ces mêmes principes
on cela heinz guderian le plus âpre
défenseur du combat blindés allemands
auraient certainement été d'accord la
vraie différence entre ces deux
générations ne tenait pas tant dans les
idées ni dans la manière d'obtenir la
victoire que dans les moyens disponibles
l'avènement de la guerre mécanisée lors
de la première guerre mondiale et les
progrès technologiques effectués lors de
l'entre-deux-guerres permettait à
présent à l'esprit aventureux d'imaginer
de façon réaliste la destruction de
l'ennemi lors de guerre éclair dont
l'instrument de la victoire résidaient
dans des formations mowgli de chars et
de troupes d'appui tandis que les succès
éclatant des armées allemandes en
pologne en france en russie et dans les
déserts occidentaux lors des premières
années de la seconde guerre mondiale
donnait toute priorité aux blindés de la
wehrmacht
il devenait très clair que les panzers
était le tranchant de l'âme de ce qui
allait devenir une troupe interarmes
incroyablement professionnels et
aguerris ce furent les différences entre
goût derian rmel von manstein et leurs
homologues des alliés qui permirent les
succès militaire de l'allemagne lors des
premières années de la guerre il ne se
battait pas seulement coopération
interarmes pour atteindre un objectif
mais également pour la suprématie
aérienne
c'est ce mélange de toutes les armes qui
se révéla si désastreux pour les armées
polonaises française britannique et
soviétique
les officiers alliés avaient été formés
avec l'idée que les différentes armes
opérer indépendamment sur le terrain
l'inadéquation de leurs théories à
propos de la doctrine des blindés fut
confirmée plus d'une fois sur les champs
de bataille nord africains ni la british
army nil arf ne tentèrent de développer
des relations qu'ils pouvaient favoriser
la très étroite coopération qui existait
entre la jeune luftwaffe et la wehrmacht
romel pu observer à maintes reprises que
c'est l'incapacité des britanniques à
considérer la notion de combats
interarmes qui donna la victoire
l'afrika korps mais le génie des chefs
allemand était d'avoir compris que
l'essence de la guerre moderne résidait
dans l'exploitation des technologies qui
avaient émergé du chaudron de la grande
guerre ce faisant il acquérir une
expertise qu'ils appliquent air à
répétition jusqu'à la chute de
l'allemagne en 1945
le renseignement concernant l'ennemi
était vitale aux puncheurs division afin
d'optimiser au maximum l'impact de leur
assaut sur l'ennemi
quel que soit le lieu où elle
choisissait d'attaquer les yeux et les
oreilles de ces groupes interarmes qui
composaient les formations mobile
allemande était monté sur les voitures
blindées des house cloud apps taï lung
les bataillons de reconnaissance qui
rôdait loin en tête des formations
blindées les allemands produisait des
voitures blindées depuis 1933 et elle
leur servir durant toute la durée du
conflit
tout aussi vitaux à la rapidité de
manoeuvre des panzers étaient les
transports de troupes blindés et blindés
légers tractant des obusiers des
automoteurs anti aériens et des camion
tractant l'artillerie lourde prête à
être déployée pour écraser tout poches
de résistance et demi la plupart étaient
des semis chenilles et une catégorie de
véhicules dans laquelle l'armée
allemande investit beaucoup durant
l'entre-deux-guerres
mais ce furent les systèmes de
communication radio qui évolue vers le
plus avec les panzers monté sur voitures
blindées ou sursemis chenilles et ils
donnèrent tags ou derian une capacité de
commandement et de transmissions sans
commune mesure avec celle qui avait pu
connaître napoléon ce qu il reconnu en
un instant bien entendu en 1932 la
reichswehr fit un appel d'offres pour
une voiture blindée à quatre roues
destiné à des missions de reconnaissance
pour les régiments de cavalerie de
l'armée allemande
avec comme résultat la quadrette 13
construite par adler et qui fut au mieux
un expédient classé comme obsolète
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale la
kmz xiii fut néanmoins engagé lors de la
campagne de pologne et sa présence lors
des premières phases de la campagne de
russie témoigne de l'incapacité de
l'industrie allemande à satisfaire la
demande de la wehrmacht pour un véhicule
spécialement conçu pour ses nouvelles
missions
la plus petite et la plus légère de
cette nouvelle génération de voitures
blindées était la panzer pas wagen 221
la thunder crac zheng ou sdk et z 221
littéralement véhicule automobile à
usages spéciaux qui entra en service en
1937 fut développée pour servir au sein
des détachements de reconnaissance de
l'infanterie motorisés et des panzer
division 339 exemplaires furent
construits avant que ne soit produit un
modèle aux moteurs plus puissants
le modèle b qui fut achevée en mai 1940
bien que le blindage n'y pas plus de 8
mm d'épaisseur supplémentaires par
rapport à la adler la sdk et faisait 221
bénéficier d'une protection accrue par
l'inclinaison de sa coque l'armement
était très léger une seule mitrailleuse
mg 34 la sdk et faisait 221 fut employé
par l'armée allemande dans toutes ses
campagnes de la france au stade de
russie en passant par les sables du
sahara occidental avec l'afrika korps
plus que jamais c'est le faible armement
de la sdk y z 221 qui amena l'état major
à l'employé de concert avec sa soeur
plus lourdement pourvus la ldk faisaient
222 que l'on peut voir ici
bien qu'elles étaient construites sur la
base du même châssis la sdk et faisait
222 avait été conçu comme une plateforme
d'armement pour les unités de
reconnaissance divisionnaire et elle
était dotée d'une tourelle à 10 face qui
bien que très étroites embarquer deux
hommes servant un canon de 20 mm k w
qu'à 30 ou 38 automatique
ce dernier est en dérive et des canons
armand le chasseur messerschmitt 109 de
la luftwaffe l'armement secondaire était
une mitrailleuse mg 34 en cohérence avec
la doctrine allemande qui confiaient les
opérations de reconnaissance motorisés à
deux petits détachements équipés de
voitures blindées
il ne fut jamais envisagé qu'elle soit
de par leur conception engagés dans des
opérations offensives aux côtés d' unité
plus puissamment armés vitesse et
maniabilité constituaient les vertus
essentielles des véhicules de
reconnaissance et l'armement qu'il
transportait ne servait qu'à engager des
forces ennemies de puissance équivalente
on supposait ainsi que le repli rapide
était leur meilleur atout face à un
ennemi d'une puissance de feu supérieure
ainsi le canon de 20 mm
reste à l' arme la plus puissante monté
sur tous les types de voitures de
reconnaissance blindé jusqu'à l'arrivée
fin 1942 d'une version d'appui 223 à
huit roues et du puma armé d'une
tourelle à canon de 50 mm en 1943 peu
importe durant la première moitié de la
guerre le canon de 20 mm étaient
suffisants pour affronter les forces
ennemies rencontrer bien que la sdk et z
222 fut engagée sur tous les théâtres
décision fut prise d'arrêter sa
production en juin 1943 motivé par le
besoin d'équiper les détachement de
reconnaissance opérant en russie avec un
engin plus adapté
comme la sdk et z 222 n'étaient équipées
que d'une radio à courte portée
elle opérait souvent en tandem avec une
variante spécialisé en transmission
équipé d'une antenne télescopique la sdk
et faisait 200 m3 celle ci fut
introduite en même temps que la 222 et
emporté du matériel radio longue portée
l'autodéfense était assurée par une mg
34 monté sur une petite tourelle doté de
grilles anti grenade que l'on trouvait
également sur les sdk y z 221 et 222 en
1942 autre variante spécialisé
transmission furent produites sur le
châssis de la ldk faisaient 222 les sdk
y z 260 et 261 était utilisé par les
transmetteurs servant au sein des unités
de panzers chargée de compléter de
renseignements fournis par l'aviation
concernant les positions ennemies les
unités de voitures blindées devait
travailler en pointe des colonnes de
panzers plus de 42 exemplaires des sdk y
z 221 et 200 m2 plus légères ainsi que
leur véhicule radio associée pouvait
ainsi opérer jusqu'à 100 km en avant des
chars de tête
bien évidemment pour beaucoup de
troubles allié soviétique leur premier
contact avec les troupes allemandes en
approche était souvent avec ces unités
de reconnaissance très rapide
rareté parmi les véhicules blindés
allemands
la sd kmz 247 n'est pas visible sur
cette séquence et pourrait être décrite
comme une voiture blindée servant au
transport des personnels de l'état major
tactique celle visible ici sont des
modèles 4,4 mise en production à partir
de juillet 1941 pour remplacer la
variante à six roues de la sdk y z 247
produite depuis 1937
le chef du bataillon de reconnaissance
dans 16 des kaizer 247 diriger une
petite colonne de sdk y z 222 de soutien
et une sd kaizen 223 de transmission à
travers une ville française au moment de
l'occupation de vichy en novembre 1942
les sdk et vous aident à six roues
comprenez la 230 et une sur blindes et
la 232e antennes cadres et la 263 bourré
de matériel de transmission
elles furent les premières de la
nouvelle génération de voitures blindées
qui entrèrent en service en 1932
cette gamme de véhicules étaient
construites sur la base du châssis tout
terrain léger à six roues dont 4
motrices que les sociétés d'aillleurs
benz mag est rousse et boussignac
produisait déjà pour les camions
allemands
bien que demandé par la wehrmacht pour
des raisons d'économie les limites
techniques de la sd kaizen 231 apparu
rapidement ce qui allait réduire son
temps de service la production de ce
modèle ne durera que quatre ans et un
nouveau concept apparu dès 1937 pesant
entre cinq et six tonnes
la sdk et faisait 231 comme la 222 était
équipé d'une tourelle armé d'un canon de
20 mm et d'une mitrailleuse
malgré une conception plus que moyenne
leur gamme lourde à six roues joue un
rôle dans le développement de techniques
opérationnelles utilisé par les
bataillons de reconnaissance durant la
période précédant la guerre et qu'elle
applique air lors de l'occupation de
l'autriche et de la tchécoslovaquie
les plus connus des voitures blindées
allemandes étaient la gamme lourde à
huit roues mise en service en 1936 alors
que cette nouvelle gamme héritait des
désignations de la génération à six
roues précédente avec des variantes à
huit roues comme les sdk y z 231 232 et
263 elle s'en distinguer par l'ajout du
suffixe 8 he had choisissant d'opter
cette fois pour un châssis conçu
spécifiquement la gamme il est rouge fut
sans doute la plus sophistiqués au monde
pour ce type de véhicule malgré le fait
que le châssis de la série 8 rade fut
construit par boeing nag la supervision
du projet et la fabrication des
carrosseries était assurée par deuil de
verre que à kiel avec un assemblage
final pris en charge par la société f6
shoah helbling entre 1936 et septembre
un total de 840 cet engin sortir des
chaînes de production
les voitures blindées à huit roues de la
gamme s dkfz 231 furent engagés dans la
campagne de pologne jusqu'à la défaite
du régime nazi
l'affectation de cette voiture
lourdement blindés dépend des de la
formation au sein de laquelle elle
opérait le plus grand nombre servait au
sein des panzer division qui recevaient
chacune 12 exemplaires
là où les divisions motorisés n'en avait
que 6 et la brigade d'infanterie sur
camions seulement 4 elle opérait en
tandem non seulement avec les autres
voitures légères mentionné précédemment
mais également appuyé par des side cars
armés de mitrailleuses
la ldk faisaient 263,8 rade reprenait la
structure de la gamme s dkfz 231 avec
une carrosserie blindés au plafond
surélevé de façon à pouvoir loger la
radio moyenne ondes de 100 watts utilisé
par les détachements de transmission des
divisions motorisés et les panzer
division
ce puissant équipements radio embarquée
permettait la transmission rapide et à
longue distance des ordres d'après les
derniers renseignements fournis sur les
forces et positions ennemies
l'une des meilleures séquences du film
montrant des voitures blindées en action
se situe lors des opérations de
reconnaissance du détachement de la
première division ss l'axiome d'arte
adolf hitler lors de la campagne des
balkans d'avril 1941
on voit ici un détachement mixte de sdk
y z 221 légère de grossesse dkfz 232
radio à huit roues et de sdk y z 231 de
reconnaissance faire discrètement
mouvement à travers une ville grecque où
ils donnèrent la chasse aux forces
britanniques battant en retraite
il est intéressant de noter les noms
inscrits sur les véhicules par les
équipages pratique beaucoup moins
courante chez les allemands que chez les
américains ou les britanniques durant
cette campagne
le détachement de reconnaissance de la
langue john carter était commandée par
le showman fureur courte meyer qui fut
décoré de la croix de chevalier pour son
commandement
ayant découvert que les troupes
britanniques avaient été évacués par la
mer il réquisitionne à un certain nombre
de bateaux de pêche hifi embarqués la
tête du détachement avec les voitures
blindées et les suivis capturant par la
suite des soldats du 3e royal tanqueray
jim heintz
c'est en afrique du nord que les
voitures blindées à huit roues donnèrent
leur pleine mesure
contrairement à un préjugé le désert
libyen n'est pas seulement fait de sable
meubles mais offre des étendues en dur
permettant aux véhicules à roues et à
chenilles de circuler rapidement les
voitures blindées rendirent de grands
services à l'afrika korps l'opération
barbarossa fut le plus grand défi relevé
par ces véhicules alors qu'elle
s'enfonçait dans les profondeurs du
territoire soviétique éparpillant leurs
ressources limitées à travers un front
qui s'élargissaient sans cesse ici une
sd kmz 222 et une sdk faisait 232 de la
11ème panther division du panzer groupe
kleist opérant au sein du groupement sud
se trouve loin derrière les lignes
russes pour collecter des renseignements
vitaux sur les unités de l'armée rouge
lors de l' avance sur kiev
en août 1941 c'est en russie que le
châssis spécialement conçu des huîtres
had fut pleinement apprécier les routes
russes étaient rarement goudronnées et
lors des tempêtes estivales des pluies
intenses les transformer en bourbier
toutefois l'arrivée de l'hiver russe
poussa les huit roues motrices et leurs
conducteurs dans leurs derniers
retranchements sur les dernières
versions de l'os dkfz 232 l'antenne
courbe fut remplacée par une antenne
cadres placés à l'arrière du
compartiment et une autre sur le toit à
l'occasion les voitures blindées était
également utilisée lors d'offensives
comme ce fut le cas pour ce groupe de
sdk et z 222 commandé par le dernier
modèle de sdk et z 232 qui fait feu sur
les forces de la guérilla dans les
montagnes de yougoslavie la dernière
variante du châssis sdk et z 231,8 rade
entrer en production seulement en
décembre 1942 et résultats directement
du besoin de détachement de
reconnaissance
disposant de leur propre appui de feu
face à la puissance grandissante des
troupes soviétiques et alliés
elie premier sdk et z 233 furent
converti à partir de châssis de sdk et z
231 et 232 renvoyé en allemagne pour
révision ensuite 109 autres furent
construites avant que la production ne
soit arrêtée en octobre 1943 l'armement
principal était le canon elle 24h tout
mal de 75 mm les premiers détachements
équipés de sdk y êtes 233 arrivèrent en
afrique du nord fin 1942 et furent
engagés intensivement dans les combats
de tunisie où ces images ont été
tournées
répartis en peloton de six véhicules les
sdk et z 233 devait accompagner les sdk
et z 200 m2 plus légère et les sdk et z
223 que l'on voit ici servir de véhicule
de transmission
la plupart de ces véhicules portent un
camouflage à base de feuillages pour
ceux masqués au regard perçant des
pilotes de l'aviation alliée
la sd kaizen 233 transporte normalement
un lot de 33 munitions explosives et
perforantes
bien que comme pour la plupart des
autres véhicules les équipages emporté
des munitions supplémentaires selon la
nature de la mission et de l'adversaire
la ldk faisaient 233 surmontera efficace
et fut appréciée des équipages
cs dkfz 233 de la première panzer
division se trouve à salonique en grèce
en juillet 1943 les sdk y êtes 233
furent engagés sur tous les fronts et ce
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
un certain nombre de ces machines vu ici
à sur l'appui d'un détachement de
reconnaissance alignant sdk et faisait
222 223 et volks wagen fimba gun lors
d'une opération sur la frontière est de
la pologne
le soulagement se lit sur les visages
quand il devient clair que la colonne de
véhicules qui arrive n'est pas une
colonne ennemie mais un autre
détachement de reconnaissance
de retour de sa propre mission malgré la
commande passée en 1940 la longue
gestation de la série s dkfz 234 des
voitures blindées lourdes ne donna
naissance aux premiers puma construit
par boussignac qu'en septembre 1943
bien que d'apparence similaire avait ce
des kaizer 231 qu'elle devait remplacer
la sdk y z 234 était doté d'une
protection balistique supérieur
seuls sans un puma furent produits
servant dans les compagnies de voitures
blindées de quatre heures divisions sur
les fronts est et ouest
ces images surprise sur ce dernier
témoignant des combats féroces mené en
normandie par la panzer l'air et la
deuxième plongeur division opérant avec
la compagnie de reconnaissance de la
panzer l'air lors des combats contre les
forces américaines autour de saint lô
les pumas très camoufler ratissaient
relais route leur canon elle 62 50 mm
leur donnant plus d'allongé de puissance
de feu que n'importe quelle autre
voiture blindée à ce moment le destin
des pumas en normandie fut un peu
différent de celui de la majorité des
blindés allemands après la percée alliés
et la destruction du groupement ouest
dans la poche de falaise produite à 200
exemplaires entre juin 1944 et janvier
1945 la sdk et faisait 234,1 armé de son
canon de 20 mm servait au sein des
bataillons de reconnaissance des
division de panzers et de panzers
grenadiers la sdk et z 234,3 assure l
appui feu parmi les unités de
reconnaissance
elle était armé d'un canon de 75 mm qui
était déjà obsolète dans ce rôle en 1944
cela pousse à hitler a demandé une
variante armée du canon antichar de 75
mm capables de faire face aux blindés
alliés après l'anschluss en 1938 l'armée
allemande récupéra 27 voitures blindées
a déjé z à huit roues de l'armée
autrichienne dont elle affectait un
certain nombre à la police 14 à des
geysers furent utilisés par le
détachement de police ss lors des
opérations de dante sic
le 1er septembre 1939
juste après l'invasion de la pologne
appuyé par les canons léger d'infanterie
una dg z ss baptisé sous des tonnes
landes est utilisé ici comme appui
mobile par la police pour prendre un
commissariat la dg z est armé d'un canon
de 20 mm et de deux mitrailleuses
ce tailleur dame leur push reçu une
commande conséquente d'adp et jay z
après que 25 étaient produites par les
ss engagé en russie en 1942
les allemands utilisaient de nombreux
modèles ennemis différents l'une de
meilleures étant la panhard 178
un certain nombre furent capturés en
1940 est utilisée 43 par française
récupérer furent modifiées pour servir
sur le front russe comme véhicule de
protection des voies de chemin de fer
l'équipe et deux roues ferroviaire elle
opérait de concert avec les trains
blindés défendant les lignes de
ravitaillement vital contre les
partisans soviétique
une fois en contact avec ces derniers
l'équipage de la panhard devait les
engagés avec son canon tout en appelant
le train blindé en renfort
l'efficacité des voitures hui roues au
cours de la deuxième guerre mondiale
était telle qu en 1975 la bundeswehr
choisi d'en reprendre la configuration
pour son véhicule de reconnaissance
luke's aucun pays n'emploie ya plus
grande variété de semis chemillé durant
le conflit que l'allemagne
néanmoins l'intérêt de la wehrmacht pour
ses véhicules préfigurait l'ascension
d'hitler et l'expansion de la wehrmacht
dans les années après 1933
en effet des machines de ce type avaient
été utilisés en nombre très limité lors
de la grande guerre l'expérience acquise
avec c'est marianne wagen et autres
prototypes servi de base au cahier des
charges des futurs semi chenille est
inclus dès 1926 dans le programme de
motorisation de l'artillerie au sein de
la reichswehr sa finalisation en 1929
devait mener à la définition de nouveaux
besoins concernant une gamme de semis
chenille est utilisable comme tracteur
en 1932 le programme était articulée
autour d'un semis schoenig et léger de 5
tonnes
un moyen de 8 tonnes et un autre louvre
de 12 tonnes
quoi qu'il en soit avec l'expansion de
la wehrmacht après 1933
deux autres concepts apparurent et dès
1934 les spécifications pour un modèle
d'une tonne et un de 3 tonnes fut
redéfinie
ces deux derniers allaient devenir les
semis chenilles et les plus répandues au
sein de l'armée allemande
le besoin d'un modèle très lourd de 18
tonnes n'émerge a pas avant 1936 un
grand nombre de sociétés furent
impliqués dans ce programme d'équipement
et représente presque un annuaire de
l'industrie automobile allemande
hocine ragued einer benz aberlenc raus
ma feuille à munich femmes aux abrets
cela au des mags dans la ruhr et
borgward à brême
dans la période précédant la guerre la
wehrmacht réussi à rationaliser le
nombre de variantes produite ce qui fait
que durant tout le conflit celui modèle
entrèrent en production
le plus petit était le quétaine rade une
sorte de petit motos tracteurs
croisement entre une moto et un mini
semi chemillé
bien qu'il était est produit par nso il
était dérivée d'un véhicule développé à
l'origine pour l'armée autrichienne sa
production commence à en 1940 et durera
jusqu'en 1944
avec un total de 8000 345 machine
construite malgré sa désignation qui le
destinait clairement rôle de tracteurs
d'armes légères anti char pour les
troupes parachutistes déployée pour la
première fois en crète en 1941 son
utilité était tel qu'il fut aussi
largement utilisé par la wehrmacht la
mobilité du quai et en rade était
excellente et sa capacité à affronter
les terrains les plus difficiles en fit
un engin populaire si la propulsion
était assurée par les chenilles la
direction se faisait grâce à un guidon
comme sur une moto classique avec
cependant un rayon de braquage bien plus
faible grâce au contrôle du différentiel
on peut voir sur ces images le motos
tracteurs deux années sous poussé dans
ses derniers retranchements lors des
essais qui montre que le quétaine rade
pouvait affronter toutes sortes de
conditions le quétaine rade servi sur
tous les fronts à partir de 1941 et les
britanniques utilisèrent souvent les
exemplaires qu'ils prirent aux allemands
dans le désert d'afrique du nord
la séquence classique du film montrant
exactement la fonction pour laquelle le
quétaine rad avait été conçue fut tourné
à l'été 1943 lors du soutien par
planeurs des parachutistes allemands
défendant la sicile lors du débarquement
allié du 10 juillet d'abord un des fps
de 130 transportant des troupes atterri
sans encombre sur la plage suivi
rapidement par un gotha 242 plus
imposant
bien que le poids du cat and he had
atteignait 1,28 tonnes il était
parfaitement transportable par le
gothard la configuration en double que
du planeur permettait de débarquer
facilement le mini semi chenilles et il
permettait aux parachutistes de
transporter n'importe quelle charge un
peu trop lourde pour être porté à dos
d'homme et tractait sans problème leurs
armes antichars
aussi mobile cachard le cadre à donner
le meilleur de lui-même en russie
lorsque les pluies d'automne et la fonte
des neiges au début du printemps
transformer les routes en bourbier en
1939 des mags commença à produire le 17
d'une tonne qui allait devenir l'un des
semis chenilles et les plus répandues au
sein de la wehrmacht
la fabrication des versions non blindée
fut confiée à des sous traitants tandis
que le concepteur se concentrait sur la
production des versions blindés
standardisés sous la désignation sdk et
z10 ce semi chemillé fut intensivement
utilisé durant toute la durée du conflit
la variante principale en est l es dkfz
10,4 d'une tonne un automoteur entier
aérien dans le compartiment passagers
avait été remplacé par une plateforme
sur laquelle était monté une pièce flac
32 20 mm 6 en 10 exemplaires de cette
version fut reconstruit quand sa
production fut stoppée en 1944 25000
exemplaires avaient été construits dans
le cadre d'un programme regroupant les
usines d'autriche de france et
d'allemagne
elle incluait sa horreur vers que à
vienne par renault simca peugeot et
lorraine en france et mécanique werk
silésien en allemagne un certain nombre
d'autres entreprises allemandes tel cas
de l'herbe ou singh dingue et niague
construisirent le sdk f10 en même temps
que les panzers et leur propre semi
chenilles et l'apparence de ce véhicule
reste inchangée au fil de sa production
la carrosserie s'emporte étant conçu
comme un transport de troupes à toit
ouvert pour huit soldats qui pouvaient
ainsi se tenir prêt à débarquer
l'adaptation en 1939 du châssis d'une
tonne pour recevoir le compartiment
blindés mena à l'apparition de la série
s dkfz 250 pour servir au sein des
unités de reconnaissance blindés des
divisions motorisés et de panzers
l'intérieur était aménagé afin
d'accueillir le pilote le chef de bord
et 4 fantassins le blindage protégeait
des armes de petit calibre
bien qu'un lot de prototype du sdk yz250
fut testée en pologne
la production fut retardé et le premier
rang jeunes qui tapent pas les chaînes
de montage avant juin 1941
le sdk et z 250 donna lieu à toute une
famille de véhicules deux sont visibles
sur ces images d'une unité de
reconnaissance de la première division
ss en france en 1942
le sdk et z 250 10 est armé d'un pack 36
et la variante de commandement sdk yz250
3 est pourvu d'une antenne cadre alors
que la production du sdk yz250
augmentait les films tels que celui-ci
devint de plus en plus courant ce film
de la campagne de 1942 en russie
méridionale montre le sdk et z 250 de
transport de troupes
la version armée du pack est la variante
transmission engagé dans l'avant sur
rostov sur don pour leur autodéfense les
sdk et z 250 était armé d'une mg 34
monté à l'avant du compartiment souvent
une seconde mg 34 été placé à l'arrière
on peut également voir comment les
troupes embarquées se servait également
de leur armement individuelles comme le
mp 38 pour tirées depuis l'intérieur du
compartiment de combat le drapeau et la
swastika bien en évidence sur le capot
de ce sdk yz250 était un moyen
d'identification nécessaires pour éviter
les tirs fratricides de la part de
l'aviation allemande
le smi chenilles et de transmission sdk
yz250 3 fut une autre des variantes les
plus répandues afin d'établir les
communications entre formations
motorisés
le plus célèbre des semis chenilles et
d'une tonne fut celui utilisé par erwin
rommel lorsqu'il commandait l'afrika
korps comme le département de la
propagande faisait grand cas de ses
exploits sont soumis chenilles et de
commandement flanqué du nom de greffe
était vu fréquemment dans les actualités
filmées ces transports de troupe d'une
tonne et les sdk yz250 10 d'appui font
partie de la force qu hitler lança pour
prendre le sud de la france
juste après le débarquement
anglo-américain en afrique du nord en
novembre 1942
l'insatisfaction quant aux performances
de la sdk et z 222 en russie menacent
son remplacement à la mi 1943 par une
variante du sdk yz250 armée de la même
tour elle a dit face et son canon de 20
mm baptisé sdk et z 259 l entrée en
production en mai 1943
manoeuvré par un équipage de trois
soldats l emportait sentent au but pour
son canon k/w qu'à 38 de 20 mm elle
embarque est également une mitrailleuse
mg 34 ou mg 42
cette variante utilisée par les
détachements de reconnaissance de la
wehrmacht des division motorisée et des
divisions blindées des waffen ss 4250
exemplaire du sdk yz250 furent produits
jusqu en octobre 1943
lorsqu une révision majeure de la
configuration des blindés dans le souci
d'une production plus facile et rapide
déboucha sur l'apparition du sdk yz250
ont eu la plus grosse nouveauté sur le
corps de l'engin et l ajout de plaques
de blindage plate beaucoup d'autres
variantes de l'ancienne version furent
adaptés sur le nouveau châssis bien que
la plus produite fut le transport de
troupes standard ces engins continuèrent
de servier principalement dans l'est
détachement de reconnaissance blindés le
rapide déclin de la guerre en 1944
pousse à abandonner les sdk yz250 au
profit du sdk yz250 et un au moment de
l'arrêt de la production de 1378
exemplaires avaient été assemblées
l'un des engins les moins médiatisés et
les moins connus de l'armée allemande
fut le sdk y z
11 pourtant l'un des plus fabriqué
durant la guerre cette machine de trois
tonnes mérite le titre du semis
chenilles et non blindée le plus produit
durant la guerre avec plus de 25000
exemplaires construits
le châssis fut développée par bourgoin à
brême bien que considéré comme un semi
chenilles et il fut d'abord utilisé
comme tracteur d'artillerie pour
l'obusier de 105 mm il assumera ce rôle
sur tous les fronts où la wehrmacht
engagea des 105 mm
moins fréquemment il tracte a également
les flaques 18 et flac 36 de 88 mm puis
le pack 42 75 mm à partir de 1942 une
autre arme fut tracté par ce véhicule
les différents modèles de roquettes
d'artillerie les verts forts comme ce
fut le cas pour beaucoup d'autres semi
chenilles et la production de ce 3
tonnes étaient répartis sur de
nombreuses entreprises la principale
était borgward complété par anne omagh
auto union adler et skoda à prague
le sbk z11 illustrait les standards du
concept allemand du semis chenilles et
notamment le moteur placé à l'avant
la direction se faisaient avec un volant
l'équipage assis derrière le conducteur
faisait face à l'intérieur derrière la
carrosserie de l'engin qui arrivait à
hauteur des pôles fournissant un minimum
de protection contre les balais éclats
d'obus
le trois tonnes montre à son extrême
maniabilité et sa production de vin
prioritaire à partir de 1943
ces excellentes performances tout
terrain même en russie poussèrent le
commandement à le fournir en grand
nombre aux troupes avec une plage
arrière à la place du compartiment pour
le transport de charges moyennes
l'un des véhicules les plus importants
engagés avec l'armée allemande lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale fut le
transport de troupes sdk et z 251
conçu sur le châssis du sdk y z 11 sa
production fut malgré tout confié à anne
au mag dont le premier modèle le sdk et
z 251 à kita les ateliers en juin 1939
pour servir au combat en pologne et en
france
en 1945 le sdk yz250 et un avait donné
lieu à 22 variantes dont deux des
premières furent le sdk yz250 es14
tractant l'obusier de 105 mm et le sdk
et z 251 10 armée du pack 36 ce modèle b
sert en russie en 1941 date à laquelle
la plupart des panzer division sont
dotés des shoots sun panzer dagen ou spw
néanmoins ce n'est pas avant 1942 que
tout les panzer division en furent
équipés
le modèle c'est en train en fabrication
en 1940 les caractéristiques destiné à
faciliter la production incluait un
glacis avant aplatit et un capot blindés
ce modèle fut produit jusqu'en septembre
ces modèles sai participe à la contre
offensive allemande de kharkov en mai
juste avant le début de l'offensive dans
le sud de la russie
à ce moment les modèles sai devienne le
modèle prédominant parmi les spw que
l'on peut voir ici
il allait être engagé sur tous les
fronts d'autres visible sur ces images
sont utilisés en france dans le cadre de
l'occupation
mais le plus grand nombre furent
déployés en russie avec la wehrmacht
ces images datant de la fin 2009 144
sont particulièrement intéressante car
elle montre des modèles sai cerdan à
l'entraînement des vaults tourne à
l'emploi de mines magnétiques et
d'autres explosifs pour la lutte anti
char l'une des variantes de spw les plus
produite fut le sdk et z 251,3 phong
wagen semi chenilles et radio servait de
relais de communication entre les
divisions de charles et division
motorisée et les autres armes utilisées
par les officiers supérieurs ils
remplissaient un rôle majeur dans la
chaîne de commandement et selon l'unité
qui l'employait pouvait embarquer
jusqu'à 8 radio différente l'appareil de
cryptage enigma était d'ailleurs
fréquemment utilisés jusqu'en 1942 la
fougue wagen et est facilement
reconnaissable à son antenne cadre
proéminente remplacer plus tard par une
antenne télescopique
c'est spw modèles sai et autres motos
appartiennent à la 11e première division
engagé en russie lors de l'hiver 1942
malgré ses 8 tonnes le spw était
facilement transporté par le
messerschmitt 323 gigante avec une
capacité de transport de 22 tonnes le
messerschmitt 323 pouvait embarquer un
spw est un des mac 1 d'une tonne sans
problème
ces deux semi chenilles et sont envoyés
en renfort pour la garnison allemande
malgré l'extrême lenteur et la
vulnérabilité du messerschmidt 323 face
aux chasseurs alliés les îles de la mer
egée étaient toujours hors de portée des
avions britanniques lors de la prise de
ces images début 1943
quatre mille six cent cinquante
exemplaires de ces trois modèles de sdk
et z 251 furent construits jusqu'à
l'apparition sur les chaînes de montage
du modèle final le dea en septembre 1943
le nouveau véhicule bénéficier d'un
dessin retravaillé complètement à
l'image de son prédécesseur
le sdk yz250 afin de réduire le nombre
de plaques de blindage et incorporez le
plus de rabat améliorant ainsi à la fois
la vitesse maximale et les coûts de
production la rationalisation déboucha
sur une machine à l'apparence nettement
plus aboutie dont les angles vifs et le
dessin plus complexes des trois premiers
modèles avaient disparu les capots du
modèle c'est son arrière anguleux
laisser place à une plaque droite
permettant un agencement plus facile de
la porte arrière tandis que le poids
augmentait légèrement suite à ces
ajustements
les performances du véhicule se
trouvèrent également affecté le nouveau
dessin rendait le sdk yz250 et 1 d un
peu plus grand avec six mètres cinquante
de long pour 2 m de large
mais même si la mobilité tout terrain du
sdk et z 251 des neg à l'aja mais celle
d'un véhicule entièrement à chenilles
il restait tout à fait performant en
terrain difficile sur une route
goudronnée
il atteignait la vitesse maximale de 53
kilomètres heures et consommait en
moyenne 1 litre d'essence par kilomètre
un total de dix 1602 spw fut refabriquée
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre faisant du
modèle d le plus nombreux de tous les
spw et transportant la plus vaste gamme
d'armement avec le plus large champ
d'applications
l'un des plus utiles de ces véhicules
fut le sdk yz250 et 1,7 kg honneur wagen
qui pouvait transporter deux petits
ponts d'assaut le sdk et z 251,7 visible
ici est en action au sein de la division
ss wiking en pologne fin 1944
les unités de spw s'aperçurent
rapidement qu'il n'était pas toujours
possible de compter sur les armes
lourdes lorsqu'elles se trouvaient pris
à partie par un ennemi lourdement armés
mais l'expérience du front russe forcé
les allemands à fournir au spw leur
propre appui de feu le développement
d'un sdk yz250 et un transportant le
canon elle 24 de 75 mm fut ordonnée par
l'armée allemande juste à la fin de
l'année 1942 lorsque les premières
machines produites sur la base du modèle
c'est entrèrent en service l'adaptation
du canon de 75 mm sur le sait fut
également adopté sur le d plus tard un
montage standard pour le canon fut
développée afin de le monter sur le
compartiment du véhicule lors de son
inspection de la 12e division ss de
panzers nouvellement créé le maréchal
gerd von rundstedt s'arrête pour
examiner le sdk yz250 et 1,16 une
version du spw équipés pour tracter les
lance-flammes de 140 mm plus loin dans
cette séquence nous pouvons voir s dkfz
251 16 en action appuyant les troupes en
hollande à la fin de l'automne 1944
les spw continuèrent d'être engagée au
combat jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
ces images datent de la période allant
de décembre 1944 à janvier 1945 lorsque
les journaux films et cessèrent de
couvrir les événements sous les ordres
du dr goebbels
la plupart montre des spw en action dans
les combats autour de budapest en
hongrie lors de la dernière offensive
allemande baptisée vent du sud en
janvier 1945 les spw avancés avec les
panthères sur les troupes soviétiques
battant temporairement en retraite
les dernières images montrant des sdk
yz250 est un pur tourner lorsque les
forces allemandes essayèrent
désespérément de contenir les
soviétiques sur le fleuve oder la
carrière du sdk yz250 et un dans l'armée
allemande s'acheva avec les derniers
combats de berlin en mai 1945
le sdk fz6 de 5 tonnes et est le premier
modèle de semis chenilles et à entrer en
service au sein de la wehrmacht en 1935
et qu'il restât en production jusqu'en
1943 sa faible production de 3000
exemplaires montre que ce fut loin
d'être un succès le problème venait du
fait que son rôle était mal définie d'un
côté ce rôle principal était de tracter
l'obusier de 105 mm une tâche qui
pouvaient en fait être assumer plus
efficacement par le semis chenilles et
de trois tonnes moins cher et d'un autre
côté ce 5 tonnes n'était pas assez
puissant pour tracter le canon flaque de
88 mm ni le 150 mm le premier des douze
mille sdk y z 7 de 8 tonnes construits
jusqu'en 1944
quitte à les chaînes de production de
kratos ma faille en 1934 les principales
caractéristiques extérieures des
premiers modèles de semis chenilles et
de 8 tonnes respectivement les cas mm 8
9 et 10 était le train de roulement à 4
galets qui s'étendait jusqu'à la moitié
de la longueur du corps de l'engin
la principale roues motrices se trouvait
sous le poste de pilotage
ce qui crée un vide important entre la
chenille et les roues directionnelles à
l'avant de la machine le cas mm 8 qui
fut également construit par dan leurs
bennes cboe singh resta en production
jusqu'en 1935 il était aussi
reconnaissable à la barre qui courait du
milieu à l'avant du radiateur du
véhicule on voit ici un exemplaire du
caem m10 tractant un flag 36 de 80 mm en
russie en 1941
la variante la plus répandue du sdk et
faisait death est le cas et même 11 a
paru en 1937 et devait rester en
production jusqu'en 1944 il fut
également construit en autriche et en
italie
ici nous pouvons voir un cas et même 10
sur ce film du ministère de l'air
c'était un film de propagande important
qui illustrait la puissance grandissante
de la luftwaffe de göring il montre
également un important exercice
impliquant les unités de flaques et nous
donne une vue détaillée des opérations
menées par le semis chenilles et de 8
tonnes tractant un canon antiaérien de
88 mm qui allait rapidement se bâtir une
formidable réputation
les canons de 88 mm sont accrochées aux
véhicules qui arbore encore la livrée
tricolore gris vert et brun
une fois atteinte la position de tir
choisi à l'avance l'équipage débarque et
met rapidement en batterie le canon de
88 mm cela nous permet d'observer de
près la procédure qui étaient appliquées
quasi quotidiennement
une fois le seconde guerre mondiale
enclenché que le canon flac soit utilisé
en défense anti aérienne ou comme un
redoutable canons antichars
bien que très lourd le canon est
facilement mis en batterie est préparée
par l'équipage
la proche des avions ici des bombardiers
dornier 23 déclenché l'ouverture du feu
même si le châssis du semis chenille est
de 8 tonnes à les servir pour la version
automoteurs anti aérien armé du flac
vierling de 20 mm et du flac 36 de 37 mm
son rôle principal durant tout le
conflit était celui de transport multi
usages alors qu'on pouvait voir à
l'occasion le sdk et faisait de cette
traque telle obusiers de 105 mm le
principal armement tracts et en dehors
du flac de 88 mm fut le canons
d'artillerie de 150 mm dans ses
différentes versions avec ces images
venues des première phase de la campagne
de russie à l'été 1941
nous pouvons voir comment les unités
d'artillerie devait avancer aussi vite
que les colonnes blindées en tête du
dispositif de bonnes communications
permettait un chef d'escadron de
demander un tir d'artillerie et
d'obtenir un appui pour faire mouvement
en un temps record il ne fait aucun
doute que cette capacité d'obtenir
rapidement des feux d'artillerie
contribuera énormément à conserver
l'initiative à l'armée allemande durant
son avance et en russie le conflit
durant et s'élargissant à un degré que
jamais et hitler n'avait imaginé et
encore moins souhaité le succès et
l'efficacité des semis chenilles et de 8
tonnes augmentèrent la demande en la
matière cela découlait en particulier de
ses capacités à affronter les conditions
difficiles rencontrées en russie et du
besoin de la wehrmacht d'une mobilité
encore plus grande
compte tenu de la diminution de ses
moyens à partir de 1942
de lourdes pertes concernant ces
machines en afrique du nord et en russie
n'était pas de bon augure même si en
1943 les chaînes de production de kratos
ma faille à munich fabriqué sans s dkfz
7 par mois ce fut incontestablement une
excellente machine dont les britanniques
après avoir longuement testé les
exemplaires pris dans le désert se sont
sérieusement inspiré pour produire leur
propre version
hormis les variantes automotrices le 8
tonnes fut essentiellement produit en
tant que véhicule de transport fin 1943
et début 1944 un grand nombre en fut
construit par crao sma faille avec une
structure en bois pour le transport de
charges lourdes telles que les munitions
en 1944 les sdk et z7 furent utilisés
comme véhicule de commandement au sein
des unités de v2
dans le sillage des semis chenilles et
de 8 en tractant l'artillerie passant
devant l'estrade d'adolphe hitler lors
de la parade fêtant son anniversaire à
berlin le 20 avril 1939 apparu un
nouveau modèle de semis chenille est
fabriquée à l'origine pour l'armée rouge
au début des années 30
si le tracteur moyen de 12 tonnes entré
en service dans l'armée allemande en
1934 la version finale dénommé db 10 fut
produite à partir de 1939
4000 exemplaires furent construits par
la société qu'il avait conçu d'aillleurs
benz par crouch ma faille et skoda avant
que la production ne soit stoppée en
1944 de même que le 8 tonnes le sdk fz8
de 12 tonnes était le principal
tracteurs du canons de 150 mm de
l'artillerie lourde
le poids de ces pièces le nombre des
membres d'équipage requis pour les
servir nécessitait des véhicules
puissants de la taille des sdk faisait
des 7 et 8 mais ce fut le semis
chenilles et de 12 tonnes qui fut
employée pour tracter les mortiers
lourds 270 ses 210 mm leurs servants et
les munitions employées au niveau du
corps d'armée le mortier qu'à 18 meur
270 mm et est le plus gros canons
standards utilisés par l'armée et il
était si lourd qu'il était démontée en
deux pièces séparées pour le transport
chaque partie a été chargé sur un semi
chenier de 12 tonnes ce vus ici sont
déployés en russie la dernière séquence
montre de 12 tonnes entrant dans la
ville de kiev en août septembre 1941
le plus gros et le plus puissant des
semis chenille est utilisé par la
wehrmacht fut le sdk y z neufs
construits par femme aux abrets cela
haut et pesant 18 tonnes mis en service
en 1938 quelques 2500 exemplaires de ce
véhicule furent fabriquées avant que la
production ne soit stoppée en 1944 l'une
de ses fonctions était le transport des
très grosses pièces d'artillerie c'est
ainsi que les 2 18 en vue sur ces images
sont utilisés pour déplacer lentement
jusqu'à sa position de tir
l'un des très gros canons placé par les
allemands près de calais dans le nord de
la france en 1940
ceux ci furent utilisées pour tirer sur
les navires et sur les villes côtières
dans le détroit du pas-de-calais
mais c'est en tant que véhicule de
dépannage que le semis chenilles et de
femmes aux fut le plus souvent employés
le plus gros de ces engins avaient un
treuil d'une capacité de 40 tonnes alors
que celui que l'on voit n'a qu'une grue
électrique de 10 tonnes
nous avons éludé la question des
problèmes causés aux véhicules à roues
par les conditions climatiques en union
soviétique
les boues saisonnière et les neige
profonde deux solutions l'une conçu
spécifiquement et l'autre comme
expédiant puis étendus à la production
de masse était disponible lors du second
hiver de la campagne de russie sous la
forme des semis chenilles et hao punch
les postes et maule tirs réalisés à
partir de canon
le premier round clippers host entrer en
service fin 1942 et fut fabriquée par la
société jetèrent qui adapta sur un
châssis à chenilles son camion standard
d'une tonne 5 capable d'affronter la
boule puante et les neige profonde de
l'hiver russe
le premier maul tir fut un bricolage
réponse de la division ss das reich aux
conditions climatiques russe
il adapte r une suspension car john
lloyd prise sur un transport britannique
brain sur un camion ford v8 et
produisirent un semis chenilles et de
transport improbable mais efficace
l'idée fit boule de neige et aboutisse à
une production en série suspension car
john lloyd incluse
à la fin 1942 opel maggie rousse et ford
produisirent tous ce type d'engin en
1944 près de 22 mille exemplaires du 3
tonnes avait été construit le plus gros
était le 4e tome 5
fabriqué par mercedes benz sur la base
du camion elle 4 500 r monté sur un
châssis utilisant les chenilles de chars
légers panzer 2
total approximatif de 1500 véhicules de
ce poids furent produits en 1944 ford
avait construit 14 mille exemplaires du
môle tirs 2 tonnes et le rso était
fréquemment utilisés comme tracteur pour
les cas non pas que 40 de 75 mm
en 1944 un deuxième constructeur du rso
apparue lorsque clock northgate smaghi
rousse se mit à produire sa propre
version
reconnaissable à son apparence
anguleuses et son moteur diesel
en 1945 25 milliards et sow était sortie
de l' usine
toute analyse de l'organisation de
l'armée allemande pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale nécessite une prise en
compte du rôle vital joué par les
automitrailleuses et les semis chenilles
et durant tout le conflit
le
non mais
m
pas nous
je
vous
demont
enfin
ras-le-bol
nous
come on
coutu
non
mais
m
je
quand
pourquoi
non
il
je
le jeune florent malouda
d'amour tout
on
tu
pour
que
nous
non
dans l'au delà